what was your first impression of Steve
when you first met him he was very
excitable I mean I can be a lot but steo
could be a lot especially when you were
using I remember multiple times where uh
you like just put pills in my food or
you know oh yeah let me just stick two
Xanax bars in sto's sandwich right now
blatantly like he knows they're there
but just make him eat these two genx
bars just to try to get them to come
down a couple notches and even that
wouldn't do it my one of my favorite
moves with steo I walk up to him and I
stomp on his foot he go ah and then I
pop his anex in his
mouth yeah that's amazing go I'm very
happy to have become an easier guy to be
around oh yeah and hopefully I have too
because like I had a long way to go in
that area